NICK TKACHOV: My name's Nick.
I'm one of the Android
developers at RetailMeNot,
and sometimes I pretend
to be a designer.
This is going to be
one of those times.
If you want to
follow me on Twitter,
just my first initial
and then last name.
Very simple.
Don't try to
pronounce it though.
You won't be able to.
So this talk is going
to be really simple.
We're going to be
talking about animation,
user experience, and brains.
So first, we're going to
start with a little bit
of natural motion
and what that means,
going to be talking about
holding user's focus,
and we're talking about
framing attention.
Then we'll get over to material
motion, title of this talk.
And finally, we'll finish
off with some Goop.
So how many of you guys went to
the other material design talk
here?
Great.
So now you're all experts
in material design, right?
Sweet.
This talk is going to be
a little bit more designy,
with some Android
implementation,
but there's still going to
be a lot of Android stuff
in this talk.
So for those of you who don't
know what material design is,
though, I'm going to
explain it in three cards.
First thing is material
design is material.
So views look as
if they're made out
of something real and natural,
so a paper or plastic or gel.
The views then
respond in the way
that material would respond.
So you don't expect a piece of
plastic to fold over on itself,
so why would the view, if
it's made out of plastic,
fold over on itself?
And animation.
Views animate in meaningful
ways and guide the user
through the app.
So Google gives us some nice
little guidelines on this.
So for material, they give
us this nice animation,
so things kind of
morph into one another.
You can kind of sense what
material the view is made out
of, something, by how it looks.
And then you can also
kind of get a feel
for how that material
behaves, based
on the interaction with it.
So in this case, we've
got a slip of paper,
and it's getting picked up
off the page and moved around.
And it feels natural.
It feels like a piece
of paper should behave.
And finally we have animations.
And Google tells us
that animations should
be meaningful and guiding.
But what does that
actually mean?
What does meaningful and guiding
actually entail for your app?
Well, the first thing is, it's
got to respond to the user.
If the user doesn't tap on a
view, then it's not meaningful.
Why did it animate?
Why did your animation kick
off before the user interacted
with it?
The second thing is, in order
to actually be meaningful,
it has to guide
the user's focus.
Your animation has
to have a purpose,
and it has to
serve that purpose.
And that purpose is
always going to be
to guide the user's focus.
And finally, while you're
guiding the user's focus,
you're going to be creating
new context for your animation.
You guide them to what
they're supposed to look at.
And your users understand what
they're supposed to look at,
and they get this new context
based off that animation
that you played for them.
So let's talk a little
bit about natural motion.
So what is natural motion,
what is unnatural motion,
and why do we care?
Natural motion keeps
motion believable.
Things animate on the
screen in a realistic way.
So in order to do
that, we kind of
have to calculate
where an object should
be in the animation
given the time.
Because time flows linearly,
but your animation might not.
So we need to interpolate it.
And that's what motion
interpolation is.
So given a formula, we interpret
our time into a set of values
that we're then going to
use to play our animation.
So there's a couple of
ways to interpolate motion.
And I'm going to go over
four of them real quick,
to give you guys an
idea of the basics
that you guys need
to know in order
to make your animations
natural and believable.
The first is linear animation.
And quite simply,
linear animation
just means that when time flows,
your objects move linearly.
So as our time increases, our
object moves with that time.
We also do what's
called easing in.
And as our animation
moves forward,
our animation will
actually accelerate.
So here's an example of that.
So by the time it reaches the
end, it's sped up a little bit.
We also have the opposite of
that, which is our animation
decelerates while it's moving.
So it starts off
really fast and kind of
slows down towards the end.
And finally, you can
combine those two.
And you can ease in
and then ease out.
So your animation
starts off slowly,
speeds up, and then
slows back down.
So watch that blue dot,
sped up, and slows down.
So why do we care about
any of these things?
So in order to keep
your motion believable,
you kind of have to apply these
interpolations in a way that
makes them believable.
So the first one is easing in.
And the reason that you would
use an ease-in animation
interpolator is for objects
that are leaving the space.
Your object is
still on the screen,
then it starts speeding
up, leaves a space,
because it sped up and
it's going up the screen.
And the reason that
you want to do this
is because it's
actually more natural.
Objects speed up as
they're leaving the space.
Your user has the time to
notice that object is moving,
but by the time it's
actually left the space,
it's sped up fast enough
that the user knows
that they shouldn't care.
The user can kind of
predict that that object
is going to leave the space.
Similar thing for easing out,
or rather the opposite thing
easing out.
Your objects are
entering the space,
so as your objects are
you want them to slow down.
User will have a little bit
more time to figure out where
that object is going to end up.
Easing both is for
when your object
is moving within the space.
So if your object is going to
be moving across the screen,
you want to start off slow,
you want to speed it up
while it's actually
in motion, and then
you want to put it
where it ends up.
And finally, we have linear.
Don't use this.
It's super unnatural,
it's super robotic.
This is what
unnatural motion is.
Unnatural motion
is linear motion.
If you want to keep
your motion natural,
use one of those
other three, depending
on what your animation needs.
However, I will qualify this by
saying that an object in motion
stays in motion, and
that part is natural.
So if your object is
flinging across the screen,
flying through your
application, or in general,
just coming on the screen
and then leaving immediately,
go ahead and make it linear.
That's fine.
Your object shouldn't
be slowing down
if it's not stopping
on the screen
or if it didn't start
from a standing position.
So how do you do
this in Android?
Turns out it's
ridiculously simple.
We have these things
called time interpolators,
and Google has built
them all for you.
You don't need to
do any of this.
Ease in is just an
accelerate interpolator,
because that's all it does.
It just accelerates the object.
Ease out, decelerate
interpolator.
And then when you
want to use both,
accelerate-decelerate
interpolator.
Just how you would expect.
And when you're animating
the view-- so how
do we actually animate a view?
Well, we grab the
view from our ID.
We call animate on it.
We do whatever
animations you want,
translation X, translation
Y, translation Z, you
can use that for this.
And you just call
said interpolator.
And just pass in a new
animation interpolator.
If you want to have these static
in your app, that might work.
But you just pass that in
and hit Start, and boom!
That's it.
Your animation plays.
It's really that simple.
All right.
Now I want to talk to guys
a little bit about evil.
I want to talk to you guys about
the square root of all evil.
I want to talk you guys a little
about premature optimization.
So what is premature
optimization?
Premature optimization
is when you take a thing
that you think is
going to be slow,
but you don't know
it's already slow.
You think it, and
then you go ahead
and you make it fast without
ever knowing whether or not
it's actually slow.
So for example, if you
were to build out your app,
and you had a spot in your app
that you were sitting there
and you're like, hey you
know what would really
make sense in this place?
An enum.
But Colt told me
not to use enums,
so I'm going to go ahead
and make this IntDef.
And so now you've
made this IntDef enum,
and and your code's all
messy, and everywhere is ints,
and you're using the application
processor for type checking.
Well, when your intern
comes in, trust me,
he's going to screw that up.
And that's all because you did
some premature optimization.
Oh, and by the way, while
you're all doing your enums
and IntDefs, your
networking class
is leaking memory-- or rather
creating thousands of objects
because you're using JSON.
So how you avoid
premature optimization?
Well, it's actually
really simple.
Fix the slowest thing first.
Don't fix something
you don't know is slow.
Find out what's slow in
your app, and then fix it.
So with that, what's the
slowest thing your app?
Call it out.
What's the slowest
thing in your app?
Anybody?
Your apps are all super fast?
All right, great.
Because you're wrong.
There is a slowest
thing in your app.
The slowest thing
your app is your user.
Your CPU operates on the
order of milliseconds.
Your user takes 200
milliseconds between the time
that they decide to
click on the button
and the signal from their
brain goes to their finger
to actually click the button.
That's how slow your users are.
Your user might take two
seconds to figure out
they wanted to click that
button in the first place.
So how do we fix this?
AUDIENCE: Get rid of the users.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK TKACHOV: That guy's
got the right idea,
but singularity is
a little bit off.
Well, it's the same way that
you would fix any optimization
problem in your code.
Hit the fast brain code paths.
What brain code paths
are actually fast?
Just in general, you have a
couple things in your brain
that are faster than others.
The first one is
colors and shapes.
Colors and shapes you
recognize really, really fast.
If you've got a bunch
of colors on the screen,
you can identify those
colors really fast.
If you've got a bunch
of shapes on the screen,
you can identify those
shapes really, really fast.
If you have a bunch of text on
the screen, that's really slow.
That requires a
lot of processing.
The other thing is
actually groupings.
As soon as that
animated on the screen,
you guys saw all,
what is that, four
by four of those dots, 16 dots
on the screen is one group.
Great, that's super fast.
If I split them apart, your
brain kind of automatically
generates that there's four
groups on the screen now.
Super fast, always, always
group things together.
Your brain optimizes
that for you.
And finally, peripheral vision.
Stuff that's coming out
from the side of the screen,
or not directly in
your center of vision,
is going to be processed
twice as fast by your brain
than stuff that's directly in
your center field of vision.
And you can actually find
out a lot more of this.
This is just
scratching the surface.
There's an amazing talk
from Google I/O 2013 called
"Cognitive Science and Design,"
and this is exactly where
I'm pulling all of this from.
And there's so
much on that talk.
Everything the guy
goes on in that talk,
like, I'm going to miss half
the stuff that he talks about,
but these are the core things
that matter this presentation.
So this is what I'm
going to mention,
but if you guys are interested
in how your brain works,
go watch that talk.
It's on YouTube, it's amazing.
He also talks about tigers.
All right, cool.
So now that we know what are
the fast pathways in our brain,
how can we abuse them
in order to create
animations that are going to be
more meaningful to your user?
Well, we create animations
that are guiding.
So we have this super awesome
animation from the Google Play
Store, right?
That Instagram logo just
pops right up to that top
as soon as you click it.
Why would you do that?
Why would Google go through the
effort to make that animation?
Well, it's because
that animation
guides your eye right there to
that point where the arrow is.
Well, guess what?
That's right in line
with the install button.
And because they put
that little divider
line right there, your
brain groups that together.
Your eye already lands exactly
were Google wants you to be,
which is next to
that install button.
They could actually,
probably, improve this further
by moving the install button on
the other side of the screen,
and then your install button
is right underneath your logo
that they animated to.
So that provides
context to the user.
But there's something
else that we can do,
and that's that motion
attracts attention.
So remember what I said
about peripheral vision?
Well, whenever something
moves on the screen,
your brain kind of snaps do it.
And that way, your user is
very similar to a T. Rex,
because both of their
visions are based on motion.
But there's an
alternative to this.
Don't move anything
that you don't
want to attract attention to.
You don't want to attract the
attention of that dinosaur
in the same way that you
don't want to attract
the attention of that user.
You don't want to
attract attention
to anything that you don't want
people paying attention to.
So don't move it.
Don't move stuff
across the screen
if it's not the core
focus of your application
or of that screen.
And then, also, don't move more
than one element at a time.
This is really important.
There should only be one thing
moving on the screen at a time.
So let's take this
animation that we had
in the beginning of the talk.
And this is a really complicated
animation that we have,
but it still follows
that principle
of not moving more than
one thing at a time,
even though there's a bunch
of shit moving on the screen.
So first of all, notice that
those teal bubbles, they fade.
They don't move,
they just fade away.
That one bubble moves,
and then expands out.
But then those orange blocks,
they still move one at a time.
By the time one of those
orange blocks finishes moving,
that's when the next one starts,
and they're also fading in.
So even though we've got a
lot of motion on the screen,
we're still only
moving one thing
at a time, which means your
user knows what to focus on,
because they're going to focus
on the thing that's moving.
That's the thing that's
going to attract attention.
So motion attracts
attention, more motion
attracts less attention, subtle
motion attracts less attention.
So if we don't want to attract
attention to the screen,
but we still want to move
something on the screen,
how do we do it?
Well, we do it subtly.
So why do we actually
need subtlety?
Here we have the
Google YouTube app,
and whenever you swipe
through this app,
we kind of got a
lot of our attention
going on in the sliding content
in the center of the screen.
So that's all great, but
then we got this thing
in the top corner that
keeps shifting around,
that subscription to account.
And your brain kind of
notices that, right?
The sudden flickering, your
brain pays attention to that,
and then, well, you notice that.
Now in Google's case,
they might actually
want you to notice that.
They might want you to
know which tab you're on.
But maybe for your
application, you
don't want them to notice
what tab they're on, right?
You just need that title up
there because some PM told you
to, but you don't want them to
actually pay attention to that.
Well, you could do a
lot to reduce that.
The first thing that
you could do is fading.
But we'll get into
in that in minute.
So let's use everything that
we learned to build up our UI.
First thing is, fade
unimportant elements in and out.
When you look at this
animation that's playing,
notice all of the other
icons on the screen.
They fade out.
They just fade away.
They don't move they, fade away.
Now how many of you
guys have seen this GIF?
How many of you guys noticed
that that's a different guy?
Your brain kind of has this
bit of an optimization.
When we interrupt your brain
with a full bleed image,
and we completely erase
your field of vision,
your brain kind of
forgets what was going on.
We can use this to our
advantage in a great way.
So you see all those tabs
up at the top of the screen?
Well, besides fading, we also
completely clear those away
with that giant
circular animation .
So we can use reveals to
kind of transition our app
into different states that we
need to transition them to.
You can use a huge reveal to
wipe away the screen, wipe away
whatever the user
thought was there before,
and your user won't
even notice it.
Because most people aren't
going to notice the fact
that the tabs aren't
there anymore,
they're just going to
notice the giant Instagram
logo that's moving around.
Next thing, small animations
can help a little bit
with transitioning your UI.
So we have that little animation
at the top of the screen,
that little arrow animation.
How many of you guys
noticed that that
was playing this whole time?
Like, every single time
you play-- yeah, one guy.
Just for the record,
for everybody, one guy
noticed that.
That animation is playing up
at the top, but it's so subtle,
and it's so small, that
everything else going on
on the screen completely
obliterates it.
But at the end of the day,
we have a Back button there.
We used to have a
hamburger Menu button,
but now we have a Back button.
Hey, that's a lot more
useful now, for this screen,
because we don't need
a Menu button on there,
we need a Back button.
We can have hamburgers later.
Small animations are
obscured by big ones.
Cool.
So let's make this stuff easy.
If you learn nothing
from this talk,
if you go home,
forget everything,
the one thing that I want you
to remember from this talk
is this one line
of code right here.
Animate layout
changes equals true.
This code is magic, as
far as I'm concerned.
Google has literally taken
99% of the animation work
and done it for you
with this one line.
What does this one
line look like?
That.
That entire animation
that's playing right now
is done by one line-- well,
one line and then setting stuff
to be visible and invisible.
So whenever anything changes
inside of your app, when
anything changes
inside of your layouts,
if you have animations
layout, animate layout changes
equals true, on, your entire
app will animate on its own.
That transition will
happen, the layout
will figure out what to
move around, what to do,
and how to move it in
order for everything
to fit on the screen.
In the case of linear
layout, this actually
works phenomenally well.
Use this everywhere.
If you just need an
animation that plays,
slot that line in there.
Boom, you're done.
Now, what if you want to do
something a little bit more
complicated?
Well, you can start
doing some manual stuff.
So let's talk a little
bit about fading.
You can animate
the object alpha,
and this is actually
really easy.
You just take the view,
dot animate alpha.
If it's visible, you
want to set it to one,
and then if it's invisible,
you want to set it to zero.
Oh, and don't forget
the interpolator.
Because you want this
to still be natural.
Even though we're
animating colors here,
we can still animate
them naturally.
Linear fades still look worse
than interpolator fades.
So how does this look?
Here's a button,
fade in and out.
Again, one line of code.
Color changing,
let's say you wanted
to change colors in your app.
Say, a button needs to go
from, say, gray to blue.
Say, for example, if you're
enabling that button,
it turns out we have this great
thing called object animator.
And we can call
object animator dot
of RGB, we give it a bitmap,
or in our case a drawable,
and we tell it what
property to animate.
In this case, we're
animating the tent.
And then we give it our
current color, the fade color,
set the interpolator, and then
we hit Start, and that's it.
There is one caveat to this.
This is API 21, but
that's not a big deal
you can do the exact same
thing in API 16 and above.
All you have to do is
instead of saying of ARGB,
you just got to give it
a new ARGB evaluator.
So that's just, API 21 just has
some syntactic sugar for that.
Oh, also, perf matters.
Don't use set
background color, use
tint if you're actually
trying to set the background
color with this.
Tint animates on the GPU,
so that's a GPU animation.
Set background color is
going to reset and invalidate
your drawable.
So that's going to be
a lot slower than just
setting the tent.
And if you're
animating, that matters.
You want your animations
to play at 60 FPS.
So here's what that looks like.
We have that
button, we click it,
changes color, everything
goes back to normal.
Great.
Animated vector drawables.
All right, bear with me here.
These are complicated,
but they look fantastic.
Also, they're API 21, you
guys can go bug Colt and Chet
and ask them when they're
finally going to drop this
into the Support Library.
How do you do an
animated vector drawable?
First thing that
you have to do is
you have to declare
a vector drawable.
You give it your height,
your width, same way
that you would any
vector drawable,
but then you also have to
define your viewport width
and your viewport height.
That's actually going
to depend on the data
that you're going to pass
into this vector drawable.
So in our case, this vector
is going to have a path.
And that path is
just going to have
one-- it's going
to have its name,
it's going to have
its fill color,
and it's going to
have its path data.
In this case, it's
string slash circle.
What is string slash circle?
String slash circle is
this giant SVG file.
Well, in our case, it's
not actually very big,
but you can get
these pretty large.
So in our case, it's
just an SVG file.
So yep, there it is.
There's that circle.
And again, the viewport
width depends on that string,
so you've got to
ask your designers,
if you have any, what
the viewport height is
and what the basis
of all the numbers
are, because it's all relative.
So then we define
the animated vector.
We've got our
vector drawable, we
can define it as an animation.
We tell Android which drawable
to use, use my vector.
We tell it what the
path it's animating
is called, well in this
case, it's compression.
And then we tell it the actual
animation, which is path morph.
What its path morph?
Path morph is here.
So this is just a
standard animation set.
We've given object animator, we
pass in the value from and to.
So in our case the to value
is string slash compressed,
and then in this
specific example,
we actually go
backwards after that.
So you pass in the duration,
and what this will actually do
is it'll play those two
animators sequentially.
And that's because we set
the order to be sequential.
And then we also set
the interpolator,
in this case it's a
decelerate interpolator.
That goes to that.
What do vector
drawables look like?
Well, remember that animation
that we had earlier,
with the Back button?
That is actually an
animated vector drawable.
So they have three lines there.
And in one case they have three
lines in a certain information,
and then they have
another vector drawable,
with the three lines in
a different formation,
and that formation
is a back arrow.
And then all they do is they
interpolate between the two.
Google handles all that for
you, all the complicated SVG
transformation logic,
that's all done for you,
you don't to worry about it.
You just create your
animated vector drawable.
And then the example
that I actually rolled,
well that's what
that looks like.
It's just a circle.
It kind of gets
squeezed together,
or rather it's
stretched out, and then
it goes back to where it was.
So we've talked a
lot about motion,
we've talked a lot
about animations,
let's put everything that
we've learned together.
So we've got our natural
movement-- accelerators,
decelerators,
interpolaters-- bleeders
and then we figured out
how to use that guide
to guide our users.
If we combine those two
together, what you actually
end up with is fluid motion.
So what is actually
fluid motion?
Well, fluid motion
is when elements
appear from other
elements, and then they
disappear into other elements.
So things don't just spawn onto
the screen willy-nilly, that's
why we're animating
these things.
The motion is natural,
and the motion is subtle.
So when things
[AUDIO OUT] elements,
we might want the
user notice that.
When they despawn, user
probably doesn't care.
We're going to be
subtle about that.
We're going to go
ahead, and we're
going to combine everything
we've learned into this one
giant heap, in order to
create the animation that we
need in order to guide our
users focus in a fluid manner.
Here's an example from
my app, RetailMeNot.
So we have this navigation
toolbar, This home row,
and in some parts of the
app, we don't actually
always need this.
So how do we get
rid of this home row
without throwing the user off?
Because this is our
core central navigation
feature, and we want to
hide it in some places.
How do we do that?
Well, we do that like this.
We fade away the background,
and the colors end up on white,
and then we just
swipe way the colors.
Turns out, people don't
notice that animation.
Whenever we need to
play this animation,
we need to play it because
we're transitioning
to a screen that doesn't need
that home row navigation.
Well, because we're being subtle
about this, because it's fast,
and because it's fluid,
people don't actually
notice that this
animation plays,
and that this
entire row is gone.
So it actually ends up
being really awesome,
and we can transition from
just the toolbar to the toolbar
with secondary navigation.
But we can make this better.
Quite frankly, we'd like to
have that animation play,
and then we'd like to be
able to tell the user when
the animation is back.
When those buttons
come back, we don't
want it to be that subtle.
That's not necessarily
the right way to go.
The way that we can
do that-- or, sorry.
Actually, I forgot
to mention something.
Or rather, I talked
about it already.
The reason that we
want to do this we
establish the hierarchy
between elements.
Clearly, that
toolbar right there
is much more important than
the secondary navigation
in this case.
So we establish that
that toolbar is on top,
it's more important, and is
always going to be there.
The secondary navigation
slides in and out,
depending on whether
or not we need it.
So clearly, it's
not as important.
Tabs are secondary.
But then we also build and
change scenes seamlessly,
so we hide elements that
we don't need at the moment
unobtrusively.
Now then, going back to
what we were talking about.
Let's say that we wanted to
have the user pay a little bit
more attention to
the actual animation
when it comes back in.
How can we do that?
Well, the way that we do
that is by blending colors.
Again, this is one of the
fast pathways in your brain.
This is going to be really
fast for a user to notice,
users are going to notice this.
So let's say we come in,
and we have this toolbar,
and we want to bring back
those navigation buttons.
How can we do that in a
much more seamless way?
There we go.
We can blend the
colors together.
So we're using that circular
reveal to kind of come
from that top level toolbar, and
then we're going to animate in,
and we're going to
animate in all those tabs.
And this tells the user,
again, those tabs are back.
First of all, it makes
them notice that,
and the second thing is it tells
the user that those tabs are
related to that navigation bar.
So even if we have other
stuff on the screen that's
going to be purple,
the user is still
going to notice those
toolbar come back in.
Brain perf.
Group stuff by colors.
We kind of had this
weird animation
in the beginning of our
talk, so this thing,
and it's kind of
interesting, right?
So what is this actually doing?
Well, this is blending
shapes together.
So outside of
blending colors, which
is one of the past
pathways in your brain,
you can also blend shapes,
another fast pathway
in your brain.
Turns out, your brain actually
does this really fast,
and it kind of understands this.
But this is kind
of a weird example.
I don't know if
you guys remember,
but this was one of the
examples that I used
to define what material is.
But what material actually
behaves like that?
Plastic?
Not really.
Well, it actually turns
out that this material
behaves similar to what you
would find in a lava lam, that
is to say, something gooey.
So with that, if we
take that gooeyness,
we can literally
create fluid motion.
So don't just have fluid motion
in your app, be fluid motion.
Have your views animate
as if they were a fluid.
Make your views gooey.
So what is gooey, what
does that even mean?
Well, you simulate your views
as if they were a high viscosity
fluid, so something that doesn't
necessarily flow like water,
maybe something
more like molasses.
Your views look solid
when they're stationary,
so your views seem as if
they were actual buttons
or whatever the user needs
for that specific case.
But they move is if
they were a liquid,
so that they can transform
into each other, they can move,
they can flow through your app.
And before we go on, I want to
show you guys this animation
by Jakub Antalik,
and I apologize
if I pronounced that wrong.
He posted this on his Twitter,
and this animation kind
of exemplifies everything that
I'm talking about in this talk.
This is kind of the inspiration
for this entire talk,
and sort of everything that I've
been doing for the past month.
So I just want
you to watch this.
Everything flows seamlessly
from one scene to the next.
More importantly,
everything here
is providing the
user with the context
of what they're actually
doing within the scene.
Buttons transform, you
understand what you're doing.
That blue button
transformed into a selector,
that selector transforms
into an OK button.
You know exactly what
you're doing on the screen,
you know exactly the
order of operations,
you know exactly
what's happening,
because all of these views are
morphing from one to another.
It sequentially
follows that views
that morph from one to
another relate to each other.
So let's talk a little
bit more about goop.
Goop easily changes
shape, which means
that you can take something
like a square button,
animate it into a circle,
and it changes that shape,
and it goes smoothly.
And it's natural.
If your views behave
as if they were gooey,
it's a natural animation.
Views also can easily create
other elements from each other.
So as you're moving along, if
you need to spawn more views,
you can spawn more
views from one another,
and it's naturally
understood by the user
that those views
relate to each other.
You wouldn't put three
separate buttons on the screen
that animate in
that format and then
not have them relate
to each other.
They should all be meaningful.
So if you have, for
example, three menu options,
you animate them
from one menu button,
and you get three
different buttons
that all relate to each other.
And the user intuitively
knows that those things
relate to each other,
because, again, that
happens faster in your
brain than if they
were to scan each and every
single one of those buttons
and decide whether or not
they relate to each other.
So relate elements
to one another using
this sort of gooey animation.
So how do you actually
do this in Android?
This is not a trivial task.
We're getting into this
really interesting part
of Android that hasn't been
done for you by Google.
Everything that I've
talked about to this point
has already been done for you.
Well, we can kind of
categorize this goop
into several
different situations.
And the first one is
simple simulations,
so something that's not
too hard to kind of fake.
And the way that you can do
this is with vector drawables
and canvas animations.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about canvas animations
in a second.
If you have something a little
bit more medium complexity,
then you might want to
have an animation list.
So if you have views
that kind of transition
between each other, or if
that animation is reversible--
so you can play it
forwards and backwards--
you can use an animation
list to animate that.
But that's a little bit
more costly for you,
because you need a
designer for that,
but we'll talk about that later.
And then we have
our hyper complex,
stuff that we can't do
this in any other way,
and for that we actually
need true fluid simulation.
So let's talk about
the simple stuff first.
So if we have a static animation
that's always going to play,
and it's always going to
be the same animation,
then we can just use
a vector drawable.
We define our goop
in a vector, we
can animate between those
vectors in the same way
that we had before, and then
we can continue onwards.
If we want something
more dynamic,
though, we're going to have
to use canvas animations.
Good job, magic move.
Because of course I meant the
animations from the other one.
So canvas animations
are when you actually
override your views,
override your drawables,
and you create your own paths,
and you animate your own paths.
So this is actually
making and drawing views
and then validating them.
This isn't as performant, but it
still works on high-end phones.
But then again,
we're not exactly
trying to match this stuff
to really low-end phones.
This is some hardcore
animations here,
so it's not going to
run on a low-end phone.
So we have this canvas,
and we drew this path.
This is what this path looks
like, simple triangle, right?
But if we wanted to
make that triangle look
and behave a little
bit more gooey,
we can add a CornerRadius.
And that's what this
corner radius looks like.
So here we just kind of iterate
through all these values,
and I show you what the
corner radius kind of looks
like when you apply it.
So at some point in time,
the CornerRadius just
goes way overboard, and it
doesn't do anything anymore.
But at that point we can
actually start to use it,
and it kind of starts
looking a little bit gooey.
So we can kind of use these
canvas animations to animate
our views, and
applying CornerRadius,
we can get a pretty
reasonable simulation of what
a gooey should look like.
If you were to start
animating your path, that
is to say, take that path,
draw it to the screen,
and then start changing
values every single frame,
you can animate this really
cool sort of gooey-like effect.
Again, you want to
use interpolators
in this, because goo does
behave in a non-linear fashion.
We could also use AnimationSets.
So for our view's that are a
little bit more complicated,
and we can't really do that
in a simple canvas animation,
we can start using
AnimationSets.
So this is a little
bit more costly,
because you have to render
your animation first.
This is pre-rendered animations,
you render in AfterEffects.
You take your frames from that
animation-- and for the record,
about 15 frames is
250 milliseconds,
which is what I usually
use for my animations.
The longer your
animation, the more
frames you're going to have.
But hopefully your
animation is reversible,
so you can reuse these
frames in reverse.
We add all these frames
to our animation list,
and we set the duration to
be 16 milliseconds per frame.
And then we just
apply it to our goop--
or rather we apply
it to our view--
and we can draw these
animations to the screen.
I don't actually have
an example for this,
because, quite frankly, in a
talk like this, that would just
look like a GIF.
That would look like
any other animation,
because it's just your
straight up movie.
That's how movies work.
So what if we want to get
kind of complicated with this?
What if we wanted
to actually simulate
this stuff on the screen as
an actual fluid simulation?
So usually, fluid simulation
is extremely expensive,
but even if we
could simulate it,
how do we apply that
to our drawable?
Well, we do that using
what I call Bitmap Mesh.
So Android has
this great feature
called Draw Bitmap Mesh.
This is available from
API one, so this was here
from the start.
And the way that it works
is you take your mesh,
in the same way that you
would have an OpenGL mesh--
square grid-- and you can
apply that mesh to a bitmap.
And what Android
will actually do
is it'll transform your
bitmap depending on that mesh.
So if you take your
mesh and you stretch
one corner of the
mesh all the way out,
your bitmap will
stretch in the same way.
So we can use this
to our advantage.
What if we could use a mesh
and make it behave like a goop?
Well, maybe we can.
So this is exactly
what I'm talking about.
We had this mesh, we
made it simulate goop,
and we applied to our bitmap.
So up on the top
screen, this is what
it looks like without the
mesh, and underneath, I
show you what the mesh
actually looks like.
So what Android is
actually doing is
it's deforming that circle
bitmap, which in this case
is actually just
a circle drawable,
and it's deforming it in the
way that that mesh indicates.
So turns out that's
actually pretty simple.
And if we take an optimized
physics simulation that kind of
is optimized for this rebounding
animation and this deforming,
we can kind of
simulate this stuff.
So we just render a
drawable to bitmap.
So we can take any view,
any button, anything
that we actually want to
do, render it to a bitmap,
deform the mesh that we
draw underneath that bitmap,
Android pipes all of that down.
By the way, that bitmap
mesh is really, really fast.
That goes straight
from your canvas code,
straight into OpenGL.
Because what Android
does under the hood is
it just creates that
mesh as an actual mesh,
and then draws the bitmap
over it as a texture,
in the same way that
a 3D game would.
That's really, really fast.
And like I said, this
is available from API 1,
so this can run on
something like a Nexus 1,
or at T-Mobile G1, or
whatever came before that.
And then we can render
that bitmap to a canvas.
And then we can actually
draw that canvas
as our view underneath it,
So that's where this comes in.
GooeyBits.
So I've started working
on something like this.
In fact, the animation that
you saw up on the screen
was actually rendered
by this library.
And demo app is coming
soon, probably sometime
by the end of the
year, and I would
like to stress that this is
an early experimental proof
of concept stage library.
This is not ready
for prime time.
Don't try to use this yet.
Trust me, I'll tell
you when it's good.
It'll be V1.
There's no version yet
So you guys can
download this, and you
can check it out and play
with it a little bit,
but it does work, and
it works really well.
The fluid simulation
part of this
is actually already finished.
At this point in time it's just
mesh deformation and bitmap
deformation.
So at this point all
I'm really doing is just
trying to get all of
the different behaviors
that you would expect
from a piece of goo
to draw into this
mesh, and then apply
that mesh to your bitmaps,
and then move that mesh around
in the way that you
would expect goop.
So I expect to be able to
rip apart two pieces of goop
and have two separate
pieces of goop.
Oh, I guess that's
twice in there.
So this is like the
bleeding edge of design.
This isn't something that you
guys have probably heard of,
because it's not
something that's
been seriously propagated
throughout the design space.
But I see this as
kind of moving forward
with the natural
material design.
If you want to follow
this space in general,
there's a lot of designs
already up there.
Not a lot of implementations,
although some designers
have gone out and made a
couple of implementations,
there's some really good
ones, you can check them out.
MaterialUp, for those
of you who don't know,
is this fantastic material
animation repository,
where a bunch of designers just
drop their material animations
in there.
And you can look at them and go
like, wow, that's really cool,
let me go implement it.
Materialup.com,
it's very simple.
You can type in gooey
into the search box
and you'll actually get
a lot of animations.
You can also follow
me on Twitter--
shameless self-promotion--
because I'll
be tweeting about this quite
a bit more moving forward
throughout the year, as
the animation library moves
forward.
I see a couple
people taking photos.
So expect one, two, three
more followers, yes.
Oh, four.
And that's almost my
talk, but before I go,
I want to show you guys this.
I don't know if
you guys know Luke,
but Luke's really popular
in the Android space,
in the mobile space.
But this is kind of my
first exposure to gooey,
it's thanks to Luke.
And I just really like that
line on the second tweet, gooey
is the new flat.
So gooey is the new flat, guys.
Get cracking.